hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar the meta genomics of dozens of
Earth's cities and one space station i
am michelle ashton of lab earth and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by blabbers and blast to you
by GMO research DiMeo research is a
privately owned company that has been
proudly serving the scientific community
with state-of-the-art molecular biology
tools since 1994 the beauty of science
is to make things simple as a mantra
that is reflected in every Vimal
research product from epigenetics to DNA
RNA purification solutions historically
recognized as leaders in epigenetics
today's Imoh research is breaking
boundaries with innovative solutions for
microbiome measurements bio daemul
research is the first company to develop
microbiome solutions from collection to
conclusion based on new rigorous
standards for microbiome measurements
daemul research has been leading the
innovate innovative to improve reproduct
ability and accuracy in the field by
developing the first commercially
available microbiome standards to learn
more about our sponsor please visit
www.gfi.com/webmonitor any time you want
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into e into the ask a question
box and click send
answer as many questions as we have time
for at the end of the presentation if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation click on the support tab
down at the top-right of the
presentation window or report your
problems by clicking on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits I now
present today's speaker dr. Christopher
E Mason the associate professor at Weill
Cornell Medicine for the complete
biography on our speaker please visit
the biography tab at the top of your
screen
dr. Mason you may now begin your
presentation
you
okay well hello everyone thanks for
joining for this webinar on metagenomics
and best practices that we've been
tinkering with and testing for teasing
out as much as we can for look at
large-scale metagenomic studies
everything from conferences to cities to
space stations or one space station I'm
calling in here from Wael Cornell
Medicine where I'm an associate
professor and also a director of the
initiative for quantitative prediction
from World quant and I'll start with a
bit of background so in particular I
think most of you who have seen the
literature and are familiar with what's
been published in the past few years are
deeply familiar with the fact that
microbes are in us on us and all around
us and probably several kilograms of
your weight is likely made of microbes
including fungi and bacteria if you
include phages which are smaller but
still add to this weight a really an
extra organ in your body that really is
a key mediator both health and
potentially disease and these microbes
change over time so if you look at one
of the proportions of different
organisms that occur in on and around us
you can even to some degree gauge what
how old you are based on your microbial
signature this is from some data just on
16s which I'll talk about in a little
bit and some of the exciting thing about
microbes not only at they're an entire
extra oregon and that their dynamic and
seem to be a function of time and health
and disease but they also do a lot of
things for you so in particular one of
my favorite you know sort of summaries
of this work is done through the human
microbiome project also work from
Mohammad Anya and Michael Fischbach that
shows that basically even antibiotics
can be discovered from normal flora that
are on our body so studying a microbiome
is not just an exercise you know really
in fundamental human in microbial health
but also it can serve as a means to find
you know new biosynthetic pathways new
drugs even new antibiotics which is
really you know kind of extraordinary so
and I'll come back to this later today
of some of the actually billions of
potential peptides we pulled out from
assembled metagenomes from around the
world and so it's exciting if there's
this really ongoing chemistry between
you know human cells we like to call
host cells in many cases and the
microbial cells although the jury is out
on who's really hosting who but clearly
you know they can and do you know
interact you can see this is how
children are Knox with the
rolled in some cases and you know what
about a more modern environment so for
example if you think about how on every
given day at least in New York City 5.5
million people go in and out of the
subway systems and transit systems and
you can see you this itself is also an
ongoing exchange and sort of interaction
environment and I got curious about this
because there's you know so many
millions of people ride the subway you
know what happens there and how do we
understand the dynamics and really dense
urban environment as well as really
large in clinical environments and even
farther places for example like I said
in Space Station so before I jump into
all that though I want to talk about
what we've learned a lot of this in
partnership with DiMeo also in the
sequencing side with a variety of
different sequencing providers including
alumina packed bio Oxford nanopore
thermo Fisher you know trying different
ways to figure out what we're measuring
when we sequence something because in
particular measurements themselves are
really lenses into how you can see the
world so we've published this and others
have looked at what are the differences
between you know 16s versus shotgun
sequencing and there are especially for
novel environments really stark
differences now for well-known samples
for example like gut flora 16s will
vastly oversimplified things and this is
because of how well it does in
discriminating similar or distantly
related species so you know this paper
here from scientific reports is one of
our works on this but Gail Rosen and
others and Hertzberg had a great paper
on this a couple years a few years ago
looking at like let's pretend today we
were to pick a new marker that would be
essentially a gene that you could use to
amplify to characterize a complex
microbial sample and if you were to look
at the distance between closely and
distantly related prokaryotes and green
and blue respectively your ability is
basically if you look at amino acid
identity to characterize closely rated
prokaryotes is actually not that good
for 16s our rub is no RNA sequence it's
okay for additionally rooted prokaryotes
but it's still not even the best and so
one interesting sort of conclusion from
this paper was that if we were to pick a
different marker gene that's present in
most of bacteria today we probably
wouldn't even pick 16s as a marker
because there's other ones that are far
better discriminatory job for both
distantly and close to where prokaryotes
and so you know this has led us and
others to really focus not so much
marker genes but do really look more at
metagenomics oi be sort of shotgun
sequence and break apart the DNA and
query across kingdoms we published a
review article about this kind of
delineating why we have so much
excitement about metagenomics and it's
mostly because of this slide is that the
it gives you the capacity to find not
only what is the taxonomic
classifications across all domains and
kings and kingdoms of life but also the
more functional and mobile elements that
are within organisms like plasmids pages
some of the BG C's that you can detect
you can't get any of these with a marker
gene and also NMR markers for antibiotic
resistance and antimicrobial resistance
you can pick up now clearly it is a
little bit more expensive and you lose
the ability to say you know not have to
worry about say human reads you're
taking a clinical sample but overall we
really are a big fans of amid genomic
sequencing whenever and wherever
possible very much else so I think these
are the reasons why so this is some of
our background there and and you know
these questions of how do i sequence
something and what are the pros and cons
of sequencing things has come up before
too so for example we've worked with the
FDA in the sequencing quality control
project to do these kinds of questions
of benchmarking different sequencers on
standardized samples in this case these
are the ma QC samples which were
developed by the FDA and with NIST
partnership with NIST which is really an
old question like if I take the exact
same two samples and some of the
different labs can I get the same answer
and we've now expanded this to the phase
two study to look at meta genomics and
epigenetics as well I'll talk a little
bit about the four more today so this
you know Guinness and partnership not
just with the FDA also NIST and the Jim
anabolic consortium to build up these
standards to really rigorously test them
and as a quick plug for that all of the
data that's made is publicly available
and freely available it Sun unbar good
for people to use for these very
questions of how well am i doing when
I'm sequencing something that's on the
human side and so it's one of the things
I was very proud to contribute to and
how about with but this is you know it's
some sense of case the human genome a
little bit easier at the GC contents
pretty well-defined there's some hard
areas we're still teasing out but you
know really bacterial genes can get much
more complicated and even be much more
in a rough in terms of the repetitive
structures so over the past three four
years 80cc has put out some control as
you can see here and data from their
group has further
highlighted the inability of 16s
sequencing even in different variable
regions of the 16s gene to actually
correctly recapitulate the expected
ratio of a titrated standard so the
these and other data have continued to
point to the fact that you know we need
better methods of measuring the
standards as well as better standards
and diamo was one of the squawks maybe D
first if not if one of the first it was
d first I think group to come up with a
mixed group standard it was also the
first and still isn't the only standard
that has both bacteria and yeast plus
presence in this case it's got sacrum I
serve Asia and Cryptococcus neoformans
as well as gram-positive and
gram-negative bacteria which you can see
here and enzyme most on some of their
own testing to show you know what if you
look at you know different methods of
extraction how does it change the
proportions of organisms that you will
see in gram positive and gram negative
and we know that there's an ongoing
challenge in the field and a problem so
these these kinds of standards are
really instrumental toward being able to
tease out what are you know really a
rigorous and accurate extraction of the
nucleic acid in a sample and that's just
at the DNA level if you look at the
computational methods to analyze the
data once you sequence it there are many
tools dozens and dozens of tools many of
which we keep on our EMSA website the
International metagenomics and
microbiome standards aligned to tease
this out and we've also published some
work on this work led by Alexa our lab
through the characterize what are the
you know how well the different tools do
which ones do better in different
contexts and what are the parameters for
trying to pick which tools you should
use so as you can actually see here you
know one of the things that we noticed
that at the genius level for the
precision and recall statistics as well
as the f1 and area under precision
recall curve most tools do not too bad
you know in that context you know again
at the genius level but if you look at
some type of species level or if you go
down to strain level analysis or
subspecies many tools really fall down
in terms of their ability to pick up at
the strain or the subspecies so this has
been you know really an ongoing
challenge in the field and we were able
to do a lot of these metrics because we
had well-characterized samples including
controls like from zai mo and others to
tease this out but to highlight some of
the ongoing challenge in this regard
that we took one of the samples we
sequenced up to about 100 million reads
and said let's just run a variety
different tools to see how many species
do we have in one
sample which is arguably one of the
simplest questions you can ask about a
microbiome samples who's there and even
in this regard it's really an
extraordinary difference of what's
present depending on the toilet use
really again highlighting some work to
be done in the field in the need for
standards and so you know we've
publishers a mission statement about
this to focus on this there's ongoing
monthly and quarterly calls depending on
the time of year to go over updates on
this and it's important not just for
work in the lab but there's other
strange places where you need standards
alright for example in hello silikal
organisms that live in salty lakes
there's no you know current standard
normally done for this or if you think
for example this is Scott Talia when you
went down dark to go to do some nano for
sequencing you can see here United to
get out there and run some standards and
you know it is actually we started doing
is running standards out in the Dry
Valleys of Antarctica and if you
consider other weird places like in New
York City this is the Gowanus Canal
which is a Superfund site that's heavily
polluted you know this is kind of a
peculiar environment as well and I'll
close with you know the subways is
another sort of interesting and unique
environment so a lot of our work in
metagenomics was was spurned but was
really spawned I said by this study we
did four years ago looking at what's
present across the New York City metro
really out of curiosity see was there
because people generally when they ride
the subway you can see here I found one
woman who was terrified to touch the
railing even though the aperture of
holes on that piece of paper towel is
actually larger than most bacteria so
it's not even really helping her to do
what she's hoping it's to do in this
context plus I'm a little bit terrified
of what looks like has happened to that
paper towel it's definitely been used in
a way that I don't have a lot of
information about but I did see one
woman on the subway once with a sort of
latex gloves created a one up here and
so the people were generally just
terrified to touch what's on these steel
railings and I became intrigued
intrigued by that as I'm a New Yorker
and riding the subways but also became
intrigued about this question when my
daughter became bold enough to ride the
subways and was grabbing poles and
riding one day and that accidentally
grabbed and then decided to lick the
subway pole one day and this really led
me to be curious to think well there's
you know so many people riding the
subway my daughter's riding the subway
what is the exchange that's occurring
when she grabs with their hand
their licks it with their mouths clearly
something's exchanging but there was no
data at all about what that was there
was no sort of meta genomic map of the
metropolis that we live in and which we
work and so the you know we said we need
a map of the metropolis microbiome or
The New Yorker called
the metropolis heard this idea of what
we're trying to build out and so we sent
out to do this originally back in 2012
and 13 and then basically wanted to
build out this entire map so we created
an app as well as a swabbing protocol
and did basically so you can put a
timestamp in geo tag and every sample
that you looked at brought these back to
the lab extracted DNA for about 59
samples and then got about 10 billion
sequence reads across them and then
basically convert these meta flying as
well as a blastic to it see what was
present as well as surfy and in all
those samples I want to see what what
what are they mapping and what can we
see and still one of my favorite
components we'll study is actually that
the amount of DNA that didn't match any
known organism with even at least 80%
identity was about half the DNA is
something that's never been seen before
the majority of the rest was bacteria
and other microbes but really half the
world under our fingertips is unknown as
represents this novel capacity for
discovery of things that are all around
us and so I was really excited by this
because if you think of like a rain
forest and you look at the richness and
the diversity the animals and the plants
and all these new organisms that could
be there most people get excited they
think about how what can I discover in
there that's really an extraordinary
place what could we learn from such a
diverse ecosystem and I actually would
argue empirically that subway poles and
railings are pretty much of the same ilk
as that they have this extraordinary
breadth of discovery and a new species
that we can discover that we've just
begun to tap into and perform all right
most interesting is that we can map the
density of different species around the
city so we can see you know where are
you in the city based on your microbiome
profile in particular as you can see
some areas were very unique right we saw
that we saw the staph aureus in
different places the menarche oxide but
also some areas like Sid Roth and Lana's
would pop up in only one area it turns
out this was the area of the subway that
was flooded by Hurricane sandy and so we
worked with members of the transit
system to get
early access to the station before was
opened back up at the public because we
got in there and sampled different
samples there are 10 different species
that only showed up in this station but
that we didn't see anywhere else and so
initially if you remember akane
sannyasis back in 2012 at knocked out
nih websites it really brought a lot of
sort of water into the city created some
of these you know kind of huge waves as
they were coming through all of the big
storm it did also create really you know
giant surges and looking in the city and
you can see it looked kind of it would
felt like this bad it didn't actually
look this bad this was from the day
after tomorrow the movie but that's how
it felt for a little while because in
particular these parts of the subway
system were legitimately knocked down is
the actual map from the transit system
the day after the hurricane hit and you
can see here in parts in light gray
urban in activated subway lines and this
is because some stations were completely
submerged underwater and we wanted to
really ask the question is is there sort
of a molecular echo of this cold ocean
water in on the walls of the subway
station so we went in and swallowed them
and characterized them and brought them
back and we can actually see there were
different kinds of species like chillin
Ella frigate arena which is previously
thought to be an Antarctic species
actually make something called the coast
of pentanoic acid which actually is
normally found this epidemic I mean fish
and something that the fish eat as well
and if you have low levels in your diet
you actually have a higher risk for
suicide so you could argue this would be
a good organism that if you happen to
come across that you might want to have
as part of your sort of subway pull diet
and you know with this you know really
some surprising features came out of the
data on the microbial scale we also saw
at the human scale we could reconstruct
the neighborhood in which people live
based on the human alleles also present
on the city services so is really both a
human as well as microbial genetic map
across the city so this led us to do
some continued work which we'll talk a
bit about today is to think about well
you know that's interesting and in a
peculiar study but I've become really
obsessed with this part of the graph
that sort of blue component which is all
these unknown organisms and really want
to know who's there you know and what
are they making like what are these
organisms doing there are they making
new biosynthetic gene cluster molecules
are they you know doing something unique
in terms of their biology and so it's
really
the question of you know you know what
have we been missing that might have
been there under our fingertips all this
time so we launched a partnership I also
got a grant with world quantum with the
Bill and Melinda Gates Foundation to map
essentially the global distribution of
the species as well as their
antimicrobial resistance with a project
called medicine with the meta genomics
and design of subways and urban biomes
and our goals here are really you know
threefold is to map the sort of meta
genomic profiles across cities around
the world and this because it's also a
forensic map to potentially then also to
track the anti macro resistance markers
and also then the new buttons like gene
clusters as a way to predict new drugs
and so in particular you know you know
we do this as a consortium across dozens
of cities and once a year we have
something called a global city sampling
day where we go across the world in a
coordinated fashion with a uniform
protocol basically swab the whole planet
so in particular we have it I can go
back here so in particularly setup we do
training rituals we set up sort of
programs to give people ready to do the
swabbing we work with city officials to
go out and do swabbing we also in some
cases swab the badge for the for the
police men and women well but we have
partners and collaborators all over the
world of health we also partner with the
clinical translational Science Center so
we have again project coordinators
training videos people you know get
swabs and get food when they're out
there swabbing all day now as we have
this large-scale collaborative project
and we also as we're collecting samples
we collect a lot of metadata so for
example where are you in the station
what's the material composed of what's
the temperature that day where it was
the humidity some other sort of
information about the samples and
generally just get about four to 12
million reads per sample pattern 150
reads as a way to characterize what's
present and so in the past few years
we've actually gotten nearly 6,000
samples per year works you're doing June
21st again this year the sampling we
should be on track to get about 10,000
samples this year from about 100 cities
so it's a on going expanded project that
we'll be planning to wrap up at the end
of next year and what's extraordinary
about this is you know not just the data
but also the metadata so we can start to
tease out other pattern
and what's President and what might be
driving some of these new biological
features so this includes interesting
things like these data have been used to
basically generate 17 new bacterial and
3 arterial phyla entirely new phyla that
have been derived from the shotgun
sequence data and I'll present you today
a little bit of the preliminary results
of the global study that we're
submitting shortly of what we can see so
far in the first two years of data so in
particular if you look across about the
3,000 samples we finished sequencing on
we you know then QC and trimming and
adapter cleanup we we can see of the the
rarefaction plot or how many species are
we discovering as a function of how many
samples we've sequenced you can see is
not plateauing so we still think there's
a large number of samples for us to to
keep you know in larger species for us
to keep finding based on these data we
can see that the species richness and
shannon entropy across the whole data
set is widely variable and particularly
to look on the right the different
cities the amount of shannon entropy
that's present really varies between
barcelona which is you know more of a
lower entropy aware than sacramento as
the greatest diversity of what we can
see in the microbiome you know for
reasons that are not yet clear but I'll
get into some of the ideas we have on
this but really there are you know each
each city has its own sort of unique
microbial profiles you can see here we
also see that the abundance of different
species in different cities is also
distinct so we see some known human
commensals that are present but we also
see you know a wide range of other
species you know that seem to be in some
cases very specific to a city in other
cases are more sort of these consistent
taxa that we that we you know keep
finding again and again mostly the like
eunuch you know vector acne is really a
common skin commensal so that's not at
all surprising but we've begun to look
at some of the other questions in this
so for example you know do we see
richness as a function of the population
density or the elevation of the city of
the temperature or the surface material
and you know so far we see some positive
trends in general for example the
species prevalence and richness you know
seems to be equally distributed across
different cities but the temperature and
latitude do seem to have a bit of an
effect these are some very new analyses
that we're still looking at for the
metadata but we do see some
potential trends the other thing we've
been looking in the data though is not
just that you know what are some
associations but what's also new things
we can learn from these data so we've
actually partnered with art bio certain
starboard bow our technology was also
partnered a bit with our choir for other
things but we you know wanted to see of
these new contexts that we've done de
novo assembly on how many of them are
potentially novel as a function of say
are they 5 or 20% divergent from the
ratio if you look at the protein
sequence identity in this case we see as
you can see here really you know
billions of novel peptides that are
really under our fingertips that know we
can have characterize and interestingly
Tokyo has the most number of novel
peptides perhaps representing a general
in sort of my career with the virtue
that's present in that country and also
you can see far and above other cities
so it's very interesting in that regard
we've also worked with John Brownstein
and health maps to actually make you
know a new map of AMR s and the
different cities from the medicine data
so this gives us a way to track map and
then also predict the new directions of
antimicrobial resistance as they're
appearing around the world and so you
can actually go to this website and play
with the data a bit and see where the
different and more markers appearing and
then eventually you start to think about
where they're going as building a model
so so far for example we see the center
of London has the greatest amount of
complexity of the AMR that we've seen
from different cities so this gives you
interesting maps of you know where are
they occurring and this you know this
led us to a number of questions like
okay we can see the game RS but what
where is this coming from and why is
this occurring at all we you know again
looked at every city has its own AMR
profile just like its own microbial
profile but what's interesting is what
we think is driving this at least based
on some of the data from we've compared
in six different cities what's the known
whe Odetta on the over-the-counter
antibiotic use and then what's the sort
of density in the number of reads we're
seeing two different AMR markers and we
can see a positive and significant
correlation between both you know
chromosome and bed and a.m. ours and
less on plasmids that seem to be the
amount of antibiotic use by the
population is to some degree reflected
by what's on the surface is in the air
of their subway systems this is an
interesting independent metric of AMR
presents and
over the antibiotic usage effectively in
the different cities which is what we
think is probably driving some of this
so we plan to continue you know this is
at least until 2020 and not just a
question of what's happening you know
really you know sort of you know in
general in a city but what happens when
a million people are two million people
come into a city before during after a
large-scale migration events like the
Olympics so we did this in Rio and we're
completely we're doing the same thing in
Tokyo next year and so this will be an
ongoing sort of quest to see how not
only where they are but how are they
moving in how fast they move so that's
sort of a quick summary of the medicine
project which we partnered a lot with
xym on this because we're using their
extraction kits and also using their
pala difficut of controls for all
sampling and other different sites so
that's what the second part of the talk
I want to give you a couple of the parts
about so there's metagenomic forensics
and then also a little bit about space
metagenomics at the end so one of the
other things we want to look at with
metagenomics is you know we can sequence
things and map them to almost species
but when all can you learn about someone
from a surface or their phone for
example so we're not the first people to
think about this of course there's a you
know some early work from Rob Knight and
colleagues you start to think about you
know what can you learn from you know
skin bacterial communities you know
could you actually have a microbiome
aura that's as distinctive as your
fingerprint you know and then other work
that's shown that the microbiome correct
from Jack Gilbert could put you at the
scene of a crime potentially so it does
have an interesting forensics
application and then finally there's
also you know new lifestyle chemistry's
you can infer just from people's phones
from Peter Dorsey and also Rob Knight
and you know we think of lifestyle
chemistry's a lot of people think of
Breaking Bad or something like that but
it's more actually like what's on your
phone the echoes of the drugs you're
taking and essentially you know what is
in medication you're taking what the
fatty acids you're in touch with so it
does give you an interesting survey of
the molecules that people have and what
they're doing in their lives and it's
also you know different from your shoes
versus your phones you know there are
differences between them you know so
here too there are distinctions to be
made based on where you get the sample
so you know a lot of these studies
though it took a matter of weeks or
months to get out and get the data and
get published we wanted to see if we
could start to do some of this kind of
work in more of a 24 or 48 hour period
so the
time we did this was at the JPMorgan
health care conference last year and we
got everyone together and said okay
we're going to collect all your swabs at
the beginnings you check into the
conference go to we partnered with
Illumina to go prep libraries at their
accelerator in San Francisco analyze the
data with meta gen scope which is an
open access and freely available
metagenomics pipeline from our group
which does basically a characterization
across human DNA other microbes gives
you taxonomy and also functional
profiles after that we also do
annotation based on what strain looks to
be present what's the microbe census
what are the classification across
different databases and then finally we
didn't do this for this session but we
normally do also annotations to get a
sense of what's present for de novo
assemblies and after you know proving it
there we then also went to the ABF
meeting and said let's see if we can
predict what's on your phone at this
meeting so we did the same thing
collected samples worked again partnered
with alumina to go this gets San Diego
did library prep I did the analysis and
presented it on the last at a meeting
and we wanted to know you know can your
phone reveal even eating or doing and
you know this has also been published by
other groups like for example can you
look at eukaryotes on the ATM's and
particularly we know that the ATM is
covered in microbes but also could be
associated with say you know different
food is a function of different ancestry
so like you know different demographics
were here if you look at where fish was
being eaten or chicken was being was
showing up or different kinds of cheeses
so you know this is this inspired a bit
by some of this work we thought well
what do we see at the conference so we
first looked at the first nineties
examples and said what do we see here
you can see human DNA and blue unknown
bacterial viral on our keel DNA mostly
bacteria mostly human as expected but we
do see a lot of you know of a few
inching trends versus two samples were
obamas controls and these are bacteria
that we expected the rest them are
actually studying it you can see there
and then we looked at the amount of
unknown DNA here in black you can see
some people really stood out in fact one
person looked almost like an alien
creature 90% of her DNA was unknown
which is interesting then we also looked
at what's the mapping of reads the
different effectively eukaryotic sort of
genomes for things like you know meats
fruits vegetables and pets and some
people really stood out
for example I rubbed an apple on my
phone before I sequenced it and it
worked so as a good positive control one
person had a huge amount of corn on his
phone this turned out to be Scott ty who
had confessed that he'd spilled a whole
bag of corn tortilla chips on his phone
on his way to the conference which
apparently was still present on the song
which is interesting this is a woman who
had just eaten a salad before giving us
her phone apparently quite messily and
this is I'm going to look like an orange
someone this is a woman who thought she
had a lot of cow DNA on her phone and
she had just purchased a leather purse
which is interesting because maybe there
was still some DNA being deposited on
her phone but the person with the orange
we said you know hey did you just have
an orange or orange juice and he just
peeled and eaten a navel orange which
was very fun and funny to see and we
also found someone who looked like at a
port forcing Dino's film this term to be
sure Darlie said yes he did it pulled
pork and took a picture of it this of
this sandwich after they II ate it so
now whereas he was eating it so this
gave us a chance to see who's the guy
pulled pork in this sandwich was
basically still on his phone we also did
some other predictions like so you know
the differences in job categories like
you know most people's phones look like
scanner airway bacteria but some people
actually did look like the urogenital
tract it turns out this was the people
who are self-identified as engineers and
this actually statistically is likely to
have come from a man because most of the
engineers are men likely so interesting
that might be happening there are some
people not washing their hands is what
we think we also did a prediction of who
has cats or dogs there's a yes or no
binary classifier and we could see a
little bit of signal for cats but dogs
was much more of a clear signal that
people dog DNA was showing up on their
phone which was interesting to see and
we also did some work with cosmos ID to
see can we predict antibiotic resistance
and indeed not surprisingly most phones
did have some but this is not
necessarily surprising because you know
even bacteria that are from millions of
years ago have AMR markers that are
present so it really affirms that the
conservation of resistance occurs over
millions of years and is something
that's not surprising it's surprising
that when it moves quickly or changes
its form or to meet mutation profile
okay so in the last few sections
talk I want to go into other places
we're applying you knows I'm Oh standard
design methods and general metagenomics
profiles since you know we've been
designed most partnering that sponsor
this want to talk about how we're using
some of their control so one of the
places that we've just used it is that
we published work last month looking at
the identical twins mark and Scott Kelly
and what happened to them when they went
up into space so NASA really likes lots
of acronyms in general they're also a
cool organization to work with as
sometimes for certain missions you'll
get a patch and so in this case we did
get a patch and you can see in the
middle of the DNA we see these
epigenetic marks so you can see as far
as I know it's the first patch from NASA
that has epigenetics and multi-omics on
it and so you can see some of the
profiles here and thinking about the
microbial profile from some work from
Steven gray and Frederick and Martha
Venera you know we can actually see as
part of the study the eating of the for
the strains the diversity concedes one
of these caused a different strain and
this will the samples taken out in the
space station the diversity was mostly
maintained but the firmicutes de
bacterias ratio you know did shift you
can see in flight but then came back to
normal you know at the end of the
mission so there seem to be a plastic
feature of human spaceflight is that
your microbiome will shift but can't
come back to normal
once you come back to this terrestrial
lifestyle we also have done additional
sequencing and are running up more
results on not just the fecal microbial
but also the buccal and saliva and here
we can see from a Disney plot you know
the buccal and saliva samples do
separate out into different groups which
is always a very good thing when you're
looking at saliva and fecal samples you
don't want them to cluster together so
it's good to see the other interesting
thing is you know if you look at what's
in the data we can see these are
essentially the the fecal samples in the
saliva and buccal are here on the right
the mapping of reads to different sort
of kingdoms of life we can see that you
know you can actually peed out other
organisms that are present in these in
these samples but basically can see what
they are eating what the astronauts have
been eating while they're in space or
whether they're here on earth and so
this really gives you a unique profile
of you know essentially you know
metagenomics of the mouth and the food
that people are eating which is an
interesting sort of confirmation for
diet and so a lot of these samples we
had to bring back down to earth it was
you know laborious it was complicated at
the cost of
$10,000 per kilogram it's not the
easiest way to get things up and down so
we started asking this question a few
years ago single could we just sequence
in space and so when I've asked
originally Oxford nanopore
is well have you talked to Aaron Burton
yet or Sarah castor Wallace and I said
no so we went and had some beers and
said well I think things should be
possible because you know the sequins
are small enough we have a way to do it
we just need to actually get it up into
space and make sure we could get the
technology work so I said all right
great well let's let's get things
started and we should actually prepare
to take something like you know
something like a smidgen or an iPhone
powered sequencer should we do that and
or should we somehow connect it so I
said well I think we can figure out
something so first thing we needed
though of course it's NASA so we should
probably have the patch and said okay
great we've got a patch set up that was
that was all set up Oh super
then we tested it in a zero gravity
flight simulator job that had worked so
we knew it should work publish this in
the nature partner Journal microgravity
so that was there ready then Kate
Rubin's and next to go up into space
made our way up the space station you
know got up there safely did the first
sequencing in space and so in the last
two years it's now become relatively
standard to do sequencing in space and
this is really some call that the dawn
of genomics in space which was a bit
hyperbolic but kind of true you can see
here at the end it was retweeted by four
people including myself we didn't kill
Trump retweet you know it's a bit early
then for Trump to be retweeting but you
know maybe next time yeah but we've
since published this also the is the
first sort of genome that was sequence
and assembled offered this is published
a year and a half ago we've also been
looking subsequently at other aspects of
these samples so in particular all
nucleic acids really deserve some
consideration so in particular bacteria
are splattered with these six methyl
adenosine DNA modification works you can
see example of it here from Eric chef
and you know we've been testing some of
these data from algorithm called M color
to see you know can we see these
deviations and occurrence from observers
expected current you can see here the m6
a versus a and you can see these
deviations occur when you do have a
modified base at the DNA transit to the
pool
or and indeed if you get more coverage
and you get you know essentially enough
high quality read you can discriminate
between the modified based on the
regular adenosine with pretty good
accuracy and so we've actually just
published just a couple months ago as a
new method for characterizing the
modified bases in these samples and we
did this actually very much in close
concert with zai mo because these are
the probably some of the best
characterize reference chains that exist
and so we've added an epigenetic
characterization of them and it's also
worth noting we've managed to get this
to work in in flight as well so for some
of the data that's been generated on the
space station we can now reliably say
you can detect modified bases using an
app or sequencing in space as well and
so what's exciting about this is you
know ongoing work from Sarah castor
Wallace and some work from our group and
others is to optimize the methods to get
this to work in space and as you know
essentially it's been demonstrated you
can do the library prep and space you
can do sequencing so you know for far
for longer missions so really I think be
you know what it'd be one of the key
tools for characterizing almost present
environments no and this includes these
diamo controls which i think are the
first controls to have been used for a
spaceflight validation the other thing
that's worth noting is we're not the
first people are the only people
interested in these datasets so now you
can see here some of the other work that
was done with taking ultra long
non-filtered deep and long reads
nanopore sequencing of these standards
so in particular the work from Sam
Nichols and Nick Loma and others
actually validated what we saw in our
data and you used our data to confirm
some of their context and their
assemblies for these AMA controls so in
particular on the gridiron of the
Promethean they've confirmed the log
sort of the log titrated controls to
work very well on both platforms for
each one of these different bacterial
and fungal species and also if you look
at their assemblies you can see here
this basically is a number of 10 KB
fragments along the assembly and you can
see down here the log titrated standards
of course have some gaps because the
species are less abundant don't show up
as much and you can see that down here
at the bottom but for sort of the equal
molar titrated mixture as you can see
you get really good assembly and good
continuity
for the assemblies and so I think if
creates you know you know again these
standards really give us a benchmark
going forward to make sure that when we
look at something whether it's in outer
space or something in a clinical lab
that we know that what we're doing is
actually accurate and it's been well
validated and so really excited that a
lot of these data come out in the last
few months to have really rigorous
assessment of these standards so in the
last closing segment I want to think a
bit more bit of a philosophical notes
and not just think about you know
measuring things but also just thinking
about building microbes and modifying
even genomes and so this depends on the
totality of information that we have
about all of genetics or what if you
were to start to not just measure
organisms but actually build them and
build microbes for example you know what
could that look like or if we found
microbes for example when the Mars 2020
retic goes to Mars and next year and
eventually supposed to bring rocks back
from Mars and a sample return mission
how will we be able to tell that we
didn't just bring something back that we
contaminated the rover with what was
being built so some of these questions
involve details of what's called
planetary protection which is to avoid
contamination of other planets by our
things and the button in the inverse as
well we don't other planets to
contaminate or something that could be
potentially harmful so to do this so if
you think about it like you could it's a
simple question but to do it you would
need to basically index all of the DNA
that's ever been sequenced on earth and
then care and compare that to everything
that's ever that you might pull back as
something comes back from Chatham or the
Mars or the moon and you think about how
much information that is it's basically
instead of Yoda not sitting there like
nucleic acid nucleotide operations per
second instead of you know gigaflops or
Yoda flops of like Yoda knobs because
the amount of total DNA it's the
equivalent of you know 10 to 21
supercomputers so it's pretty it's a lot
of data if you were to actually index
all the DNA and earth that could be
there and if you were to use it as a
computation it's pretty impressive but
you know we don't have to do just that
we were working on methods to do this
and so are many others but we don't have
to do that alone we can also
sequence within the cleanroom as a good
proxy for something that might be a
false positive so we've been working
with a Venkat from JPL and basically
it's swabbing
clean rooms as you're building robots as
they're building the spacecraft and
characterizing was present on them and
then sequencing them we've also been
looking at what's growing on the walls
of the space station and what's actually
present on the ISS was another sort of
you know catalog of where DNA can and
and will appear now the other thing
we've looked at is you know this catalog
we then compare to what's on the
astronauts before and after they go up
so from mark and Scott Kelly we've seen
that you know was microbial tracking
data which is on the station we compare
that to the astronauts data and we can
start to build these maps for the first
time of what's being transferred from
the astronauts of the space station and
vice versa or in the process of
submitting these papers now and so it's
interesting we can see you know working
with doctor cut serve and carrots when
we can actually see some of these
dynamics by comparing astronaut data to
the microbial data on the ISS and which
gives us kind of interesting you know
closed environment and seeing how
microvia dynamics you know move around
especially on that environment so some
ongoing work there and this ends again a
bit more of a almost philosophical
notice that we conclude you for example
engineer the microbiome of astronauts to
help them for long term missions or our
engineer the genomes of astronauts
potentially so they can make more of
their essential amino acids if you know
it seems like there are some ways to do
it potentially but then it begs the
question of well should we do such a
thing is that a good idea at all to
actually start to even plan for such a
thing but you know these discussions of
course involves really big eyes big
questions of editing and the rights and
responsibilities to do such a thing I
think it's it's far away now at least in
practice because this is more of a
philosophical discussion but work from
genkai he has shown that even Chris
bring human embryos and having them be
born has already happened so this is no
longer just philosophical debate it's
interesting thing about you know how how
it might be applied someday or should it
be apply and this includes you know
human DNA as well as microbial
engineering for both the space station
as well as the human microbiome that
gets sent out to faraway places so if
you think about you know going to Mars
for example the time I'll take to get
there and engineering astronauts and
their microbiomes or even engineering
the planet's microbiome so it could be
sustainable for human life it seems like
a really audacious
Skol but I would argue that you know
we're already doing that on earth having
a planetary scale monitoring measuring
and also a manipulation sometimes not
that well but you're doing it on Mars
well actually just be the second time
that we've done this not the first and
then to a large degree I think we'll
have to think about things from the
totality of human genetics microbial
genetics the interaction the environment
and think about ways that we measure
that model and even engineer it and
along the way we'll need really good
methods for all the extraction all the
sequencing all the controls and all the
characterization for both improved
biomedical applications as well as for
some of these engineering ideas
so in conclusion thank you for your time
and I'll say that you know we've seen is
that people's phones and high tech
services look generally like skin they
have a lot of unknown sequences and that
we have so far millions of potential
buzz meta gene clusters and billions of
peptides across the whole data set the
these diamo standards I mentioned are
available for ordering and testing and I
highly recommend them for positive
controls on every 96 well plate we run
on lab we have as I am Oh control just
to make sure that we have a little bit
of sanity check every time we do
multiplexing and forensic supply all
kingdoms of life including on your phone
and we do see that the AMR marker is
data coming out of meta stuff looks like
it's related and sort of really an echo
of the over-the-counter antibiotic use
or access to it which is which is
interesting to think about as a metric
for different cities and what we observe
and working with Sarah castor Wallace
and Erin Burton house okay Ruben's
we do a first demonstration of some ISS
based sequencing and Mar detection and
this is now ISS validated hardware that
people can submit grants to NASA or to
cases for a work to do on the space
station and do sequencing so at the end
I can't really have to thank everyone in
lab because none of this would be
possible without them they are superb
they're awesome and inspiring I want to
thank also that JPL and NASA
collaborators Stacy Horner Venkat and
Charles to helping with some of these
collaborations thanks also to
collaborate up a lot with medicine all
over New York City and around the world
for collecting samples
thanks very much to funding of course
from now several quant Gates Foundation
D NIH and the star cancer consortium and
finally thanks to many clevers friends
colleagues
and many people helped along the way and
I am happy to take any questions
Thank You dr. mason for your informative
presentation we will now start the Q&A
portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for all right let's get
started
our first question is does any system
provide a more accurate profile based on
using mock microbial communities good
question so the short answer is yes and
it depends on where you're looking at so
long reed platforms give you better
ability to do contiguous assemblies to
characterize get through repetitive
regions Illumina has the best you know
single nucleotide accuracy so if you're
looking for snips that still is is the
best in the short-term PacBio if you do
circular consensus sequence reads that
actually can get even greater active c4
snips assuming that you have enough
coverage to get CCS reads but that that
is if you've got enough coverage and B
input and that's arguably even the best
way for steps and then 10x genomics is
there's a newer work in metagenomics
happening there but it is also helping
for assembly and for mapping and so they
are different but it's also we're doing
that PacBio and Oxford nanopore the only
two that can give you the epigenetic
modifications at least natively you know
Illumina you could do bisulfite
treatment and then infer it but on the
native single molecule methods give you
a capacity to look at all the base
modifications as well
thank you while meta genomic approaches
can track the presence of any one
organism will there ever be the ability
to track whether the organism was in
fact alive at the time of collection
versus just a DNA RNA remnant using NGS
yes so that is a great question so there
are you know this used to be about three
or four years ago it was not really not
that possible frankly to do it but there
are multiple ways in which you can
characterize this so there's inferred
replication rates something called I rep
is one of the tools there's some other
tools that have come out since then that
let you basically you know distinguish
whether something was alive or dead
based on the coverage statistics of
what's present you know across the
coverage of the genome so if most
genomes that are circular you know if
you actually have even coverage across
the genome indicates it's not
replicating that fast whereas if you
actually have you know the spiking at
the origin of replication that then does
indicate that you actually have
something that's actually it's alive and
in replicating so I think you know this
is a you know this is no ways we just
from DNA you get a lot more information
about what's what's happening in a
sample so there there were as I
mentioned as I rep is one way but
there's also another method that was
called grid for the growth rate index
method that was published just like last
year
great thank you all right your next
question is are these large-scale
studies discovering any novel
antimicrobial resistance markers not
predicted by smaller or directed studies
or alternatively discovering unpredicted
variations on existing markers good
question so so far we focused on the
known markers in the comprehensive
antibiotic resistance database or card
but we there are many fragments that
look like they're distinct new markers
we haven't focused too much on them yet
but mostly so far we're looking at
variations of existing markers and
seeing how and when they move and to
what degree
you
great thank you looks like that time for
one more question
as people are constantly traveling and
settling around the world do you think
that distinct regional microbial
molecular signatures will spend possible
in the future and if so what do you
think is the primary driving force
between the microbial profile of any one
region yeah I think this is a bit like
human allele fractions that as people
travel more
the uniqueness features will decrease
over time but the reservoirs for
bacterial sequences and cells is so vast
I do think that you'll see you know some
signatures especially in highly diverse
areas might be able to maintain you know
in perpetuity and a lot of is based on
the things that we know from Exedy
ecology like temperature and humidity as
well as elevation do seem to you know
drive these changes but another one
that's very novel is oh you know
antibiotic usage which also drives it so
there are new human derived drivers as
well as environmental mediators of these
dynamics and I think they're all in play
but I think you know I think I think
you'll still have them in the future
thank you again dr. Mason for your time
today in your important research we
would also like to thank labyrinth and
our sponsors IMO research for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and
further interesting questions questions
we do not have time for today and those
submitted during the on demand period
will be addressed at a speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration laborat will alert
you via email when it's available for
replay we encourage you to share that
email with your colleagues who may have
missed today's live event until next
time goodbye